you
so okay this is a crazy house 45-minute
tournament to zero time control I'm
going with this this is a new thing that
I've been trying a new thing that I have
been trying this stuff and let's try and
control some squares mm-hmm throw them
in right there be a pest night be a big
pest have to watch out for a night check
right here let's get my rook there yes
feel the pain feel that pain keep
control over this guy mm-hmm let's put
app on there I don't have any drops left
but mm-hmm
let's push let's see what they do
mm-hmm gonna give me the Queen Queen
exchange mate on g2 they're covering it
they're onto my tricks I have another
pawn I could drop okay let's chase that
night away and you've made on g2 prepare
to run that's going to be pretty painful
mmm
let's try it they're gonna take here and
then take my rook mmm Knight check oh
boy
guess who's gonna be made it soon yeah
it's kind of like that that's me back to
tournament that guy's smashed me oh he
saw all my tactics as soon as I tried
controlling a square in his position
he's like no I'll drop a piece in there
and control it show you I'll show you
I'm still gonna try this little trick me
five Bishop here and just sack enough to
invite that King forward bishops they're
garbage they're garbage
maybe I'll have success against other
players all right Knight look at oh no I
thought that I thought I was just gonna
grab some pawn there okay now let's make
some magic happen I need a knight I need
a knight give me a knight right here
bring the pain give me some material to
work with here mm-hmm there's that there
is that move huh okay let's go here oh
they're just killing they're killing all
my material this was not a good strategy
they're gonna win my queen Wow now
they're just building up okay yeah they
really uh got rid of my attack didn't
they
oh this is so painful man this is really
painful yeah they just ripped the heart
out of my structure this was foolishness
I'm just made
night here pond here oh man why'd they
go with the pond there they twine with
me is that what's happening
that'll scare well that's sure to scare
him not quite sure with that oh my
goodness
killer man yeah when in doubt play b5 in
crazy house that's going to save you
that's certainly going to save you I
don't know why they're not killing me I
have no chance this one is so bad I need
to come up with a different strategy you
see it was working I'm gonna drop a rook
right here yeah Knight hears me they had
made earlier why are they going with
this they just want to see me struggle
I got a knight and a rook and a pond
um here I guess they're gonna dropped
another piece there felt like they could
have already beaten me like seven times
over
rook there's mate over there back to
tournament
oh four - oh God we got action we got
action I I'm still gonna go with that
little trick I just I was too quick to
grab to make that Knight move you have
to believe me I know I'm gonna get some
kind of a pawn chain going on you'll see
what I mean you'll see what I mean
f5 okay this is this is where the
comeback begins right here
alrighty slow start slow start
sometimes the knight move is better here
that way you avoid any pins let's do
that also watch over f2 prepare to
capture with the piece if your King has
to move forward not so sure about that
threatening a night check this is pretty
common
okay let's throw this in right now okay
let's get a piece out playing fast
that's about it though okay and now
you're not playing fast hmm okay they're
gonna do a bishop in I guess this could
hurt Bishop here I'm gonna play rook g1
I could think about taking the night
thinking about taking the night and then
dropping a knight in here
sacking my queen you know mm-hmm that is
an idea I'm controlling some squares
around there King
I'm doing this so that some piece
doesn't drop here you know if there's
cuz I if this Jeep on has to move there
so now I have this there's no piece drop
here well I could take so I have a
bishop it's kind of focused on these
light squares 30 seconds 23 oh they
moved okay Bishop be a pest that are
gonna lose on time mm-hmm might get the
first W maybe maybe drop a knight here
one day uh-huh
I got a defend here now they're gonna
lose on time I'll take him okay
I got nights here I could be dropping
there down on time back to tournament
how are things looking in the
leaderboard here somebody has nine I'm
at 240 seventh place 75 competitors in
this crazy house two-minute tournament
all right I like seeing the French
defense and crazy house this square
right here this typical move is not good
let's see how to try to take advantage
of the the French defense and crazy
house the ship takes pawn is an idea all
right give me your bishop there you go
and now we're gonna drop that guy right
in there looking for mates already
somehow a night here there
I want a knight here not afraid of that
let's develop and fight my pawn forward
mm-hmm Bishop here caught in a crossfire
oh that's painful there goes the Queen
there we go
this pawn right here target the pawn on
g7 try and strip their defenses on right
here with check now we're cooking now
that's me back determine okay we got
four coming up the ranks here 26th this
is a big game now I'm on streak I am on
streak oh this is a tough one I'm on
streak important win you get four are
they gonna take this pawn hmm all right
let's see what you do let's see what you
have up your sleeve let's start with
this control this square hmm they are
all over my tricks mm-hmm okay let's go
here if this bishop moves I'm going to
drop a pawn on h3 that'll scare him okay
I got a knight
now you have a pawn to g4 okay let's go
right here weaken their structure
immediately okay I'm gonna do something
defensive I'm going to develop this pawn
to my Kings defense they're not going to
take that pawn mm-hmm that move all
right I need some defense let's go with
this counter punch there you go now
you're cooking oh they still took okay
let's let's kind of build up my king
position now ooh let's stay out of a
pawn drop with tempo cover this square
it's important mmm mm-hmm
let's go here defense defense this guy
is he playing chess or is this football
what's going in okay you got a tricky
night don't lose sight of what you have
here let's grab this guy you got a pawn
now go here throw a punch at the rook
there you go you got another Knight ooh
I'm liking it
I'm liking the the firepower I hear I'm
here I got the knight pair I could drop
any moment mm-hmm watch out watch out we
got the rook hit the knight hit Oh hmm
No
on drop ok I got a pack up and run um oh
boy ok Africa oh they have that30 you're
gonna do a workshop they don't have any
more drops ok if they don't have
something good here I got them cuz I'm
gonna build up my King safety oh man
they have a pawn drop let's take this
guy I throw I only have 17 seconds
ok I'm gonna be dropping pawns like
pieces like crazy now a rook for
starters I'm gonna bring the heat while
joking prepare to run buddy yes I saw
that one coming now prepare for this or
a rook drop right here oh yeah
it's happening it's happening let's
start with something man oh oh I'd
better make something happen fast
mmm I got the Queen it's a check I don't
have any time I don't have any time man
oh can I get it it's a check
I need Knights right there's are we mate
yet that's not mate I'm down on time I
can't drop those guys fast enough I need
increment okay I gotta go quicker man I
was I was trying to calculate all those
punches being thrown at my king okay all
right um let's go here I don't think the
Sicilian is good let's go here mmm
let's get the Queen
and maybe go here next No right here um
alright I understand
I see let's go here so this is so far
looking only like regular chests all
right those dark squares men after one
capture then it's officially crazy
let's get rolling here starting with
that and now what do we do kick this
Knight out of there I want I want a
night so I could drop them into c7 can
you help me with that
mm-hmm I got exactly what I wanted
pawn takes I get the rook which will
mate mm-hmm stopping all my tricks all
right let's go here I'm gonna drop a
knight on f6 or Bishop what do they have
anything good like a trap their queen a
bishop on c7 or a knight back on c7
let's go out the night because it gives
Czech Bishop e7 if King f8 lets pre move
that okay Queen Queen mate right here
all right I got a lot of material I
better win this one I have time
ninety-six Queen to eight that's me back
to tournament I'll take it 26th I got
six mmm killer man lost last I have no
games where I earned four top page
somebody has 20 man how much more time
is left less than 1/2 hour
okay man I felt good about that last
game I lost it was just a clock issue
man I had him on the ropes I know I had
a mate I know I had a me
I think they eat I think they need to go
further hmm yeah let's just think about
it right lose on time again that's your
plan let's take him out and just take a
pond and have the Queens come out no
let's take there let's go there
control squares around the king and
they're having none of it
none of it okay let's throw a bishop in
the mix okay let's take that and go here
watch out
tricky night oh yeah now we're cooking
keep throwing punches coordinate your
pieces that's a check pick up the rook
they're gonna grab the night oh I think
I want another pawn yeah let's do that
let's anchor my knight in there and then
go here next no my Knights not budging
not happening oh yeah
bring me the Queen where's the mate
where's the mate it oh I don't have
another pawn
okay I need more fuel let's give a check
grab the rook on push here let's go
there for starters take that Oh
dangerous person
dangerous person
okay I should have enough here let's
start with Bishop check I want to take
that night let's check the initiative
initiative here all my goodness
I totally missed that my queen is
hanging okay um let's take that I keep
going giving checks here hmm not cool I
gave them a moment to breathe now I'm in
trouble
mates right here okay new queen back oh
my god I almost missed mm8 so ridiculous
so ridiculous okay we got eight we're
once again ready to maybe win a game and
get a big four points can you make it
happen
meanwhile somebody has 34:34 night here
pawn shop here traps the Queen
I remember that those of you fighting
those of you playing the Sicilian hmm
let's take them here we go Knight drop
here 94 90 op on d6 um alright let's
open it oh yeah there we go
now we're cooking there we go that
ripped the heart out of their structure
oh yeah
bringing the pain give me the quick they
resigned that's what I need back to
tournament quick four I got 12 cracking
single digits lookout 12 12 12 and well
we're still not on the front page let's
make it to the front page man here we go
all righty I'm still gonna try for this
even on Knight to f3 okay I'm happy with
that enough to worry about their light
square Bishop let's take him right out
and put upon right here where that guy
controlled
all right let's no no no I didn't want
to do that okay my knight wants to go
here man I'm L slipped Knight to e7
giving material back play this if you're
not careful hmm let's go there I want to
take and put another Bishop here get
back here yes this is this is progress
it's his progress I want a knight
somewhere oh I want a queen let's get a
queen trade right um I think that pawn
would have hurt me threatening some
stuff okay
maybe a pawn
I don't know upon on g3 how about that
really all right I'll take that Bishop
you're gonna do a knight check are ya oh
boy
oh yeah um they're gonna put a bishop
here and get a queen hang on hang on
hang on mm okay prepare
run King what's happening it's gonna
it's gonna hurt this is gonna hurt they
have a queen they definitely have a
queen hmm they have a petrol at least
drop off air drop Queen here - here give
me a moment to cover my squares man oh
you really went with that um you pawn
grabber man I should be able to whip
something together here I see it I see
it clean drop are a knight drop on e3
you look out hmm he's running for his
life
oh gotta go here I think is this
survivor sir survivable it's close one
no soup for you man no soup you'll see
no more of this diagonal I'll take him
gimme you can't get my king he's too
crazy nope it's not happening you're out
of fuel I got back the initiative yes
hmm
enough enough man I have a queen queen
of to scholars mate style they don't
have anymore drops they don't have any
more checks Queen f2 oh yeah back to
turn I'll take it
scholars it's the crazy house scholars
bait man they've just got scholar he
just got scholar dwith the queen drop on
f2 watch out for this scholars mate hmm
crazy house style alright I love seeing
the French man
give me the French me the French defense
I love it I love the weaknesses that the
French defense gives right here yes
remember this little trick so just an
opening it's just an opening trap in
crazy house you know I have no idea if
this is correct but yeah I've had some
really nice success with this this
bishop idea this pawn you could feel the
pain he brings to the black position
these guys are just killed the bishops
are expendable they're probably the
worst piece in crazy-house so let's go
here and then Bishop here kill this
night and then maybe drop a knight here
what do you think about that
uh-huh well let's start with this and
then here take my knight
pound drop here at some stage okay could
drop another Bishop here hit the Queen
we're inching closer hmm where's the
mate where is that mate um let's go here
Queen takes pawn Queen takes f7 what are
the chances one game would end with
Queen f2 mate and then Queen f7 mate
never gonna happen Bishop drop here it
might happen Queen takes f7 Bishop here
no that's a pinned piece though I can
maybe even take here and somehow we've
um a bishop here is probably good I'm on
their queen
scratch that I'm on their queen and
they're down on time okay let's proceed
carefully here okay come on man
I've already dropped the piece there no
let's not get too crazy hit the Queen
again and then a pond right here no
bishop I like the pawns on the seventh
rank they're animals
hmm I feel like I could sack here let's
take that ah they could take with the
night hmm
Oh No why'd you do that let's take care
I think I have a I could make some magic
happen with just these pawns and bishops
oh you most certainly can there you go
now we're cooking we got a clean drop
incoming on that Square and that's me oh
look at this monster Wow 57 I have 20
shooting for the podium in give me that
third place give me that third
all right are they gonna grab that e5
pawn I'll take them here we go let's see
what you got
watch out for my knight Knight g4 King G
one pawn drop f2 mate watch out for f2
okay all right now right all right I got
another piece involved now pawn right
here mmm they're still gonna do that
yeah you know what I'm taking him it's
Queen sac variation it's a trap
threatening their queen I have this
square covered there's no Queen drop
here hitting their Queen width check I
got a tricky night man he's super
valuable I had to do that I had to do
that did you really have to do that okay
I have a bishop here after I take this
guy the bishop drop here
that's check I got mate made on f2 again
oh I can't take my knight because of a
knight drop here mate maybe I was too
quick with the Queen drop mm-hmm they're
threatening Queen here mate let's grab a
bishop they only have a
Queen they could have a knight or a pawn
or another night mmm so I'll punch back
that's a good defensive move strike back
they're down on time
okay Queen oh yeah I could take and then
play Knight here but I just like this no
queen sack hitting the Queen threatening
mate and the rook Forks they know of any
time 20 seconds
bringing the heat oh just take the Queen
right yeah you're not gonna leave
something dangerous here with upon two
pawns not afraid of that yep
right here you only have a couple pawns
I got another Queen Queen f2 and then
Queen takes Bishop is the threat they
resigned back determine yeah there
wasn't going to be a defense they're too
little firepower
well raise 4/3 huh 72 43:27 okay 13
minutes left possible a possible podium
appearance oh man
and this guy's berserk me he only needs
a minute to dust me off here as you seen
this variation before all right let's
see what you got let's see i'm gonna
play h3o whole look at this look at this
hmm no let's see if you're prepared with
this all right all right let's
now we're gonna have to start yeah yeah
this this is scary this is pretty scary
wow this guy has it's got everything
going on here really really just like a
machine machine like man pawn drop here
wow really I'm gonna resign this back to
Tournament is this the leader yo and
he's berserk you everybody I don't know
about that that's crazy man that's crazy
okay let's castle mmm let's do that 94
okay we're taking the night and dropping
a knight into this square this gap right
here on d6
oh yeah pre move almost there we go
no we're cooking um
let's open up this Bishop huh there we
go give a check and let's take here
that's a free pawn yeah
I'm swarming the King now mm-hmm all
right uh let's see all right we're gonna
go with the Queen sac let's be bold
let's be bold I should have something
here let's take take again trusting I'm
trusting my pawn in Knight position yeah
this should work oh yeah oh where are
you going - man I thought you had to go
the other way no you don't all right hmm
there you go
hit the Queen I still have something
good here I'm pretty sure all these
squares I'm controlling dark square
control that's the strategy don't give
your opponent a moment to breathe you
gonna hit my king with the check bishop
check a block not afraid of that pawn
drops I got them covered no pawn shops
with check thirty-five seconds less than
thirty I could do time burner drops okay
throw a punch back at the bishop yes can
you take spawn I'm ready to take this
I'm prayed take both Queens now I'm
gonna get a queen yes take that Queen
well surely there's something good here
man
certainly something good here night drop
right here queen f squeen c7 is the
threat and take my bishop aren't you
feel at less than 10
preme of this that's mate doctor
tournament 81 43:32 this is somebody I
don't believe I just don't believe this
person it's too good man too good 26 -
strong man too strong
all right yeah this con it's con
Sicilian I don't know about the con sus
Elyan its structure here we go all right
let's take him out same treatment here
focus to pick one Square and focus in on
it
pieces on those squares are devastating
all right okay let's take a pond drop
one in here mm-hmm all right drop a pone
right there throw a punch Knight c7
killer two knights there's a check and I
really just want to have a queen trade
now you know what I mean hmm how can I
be
let's start with that good luck Queen
trying to find a square good luck trying
to find a square Queen yes
harass the Queen Queen trade is what I
want
hmm okay I'm kind of I need something
here
I need something all right let's go here
I want to Queen trade clean hear me
mm-hmm do this they're pointing in a Oh
take a bishop I almost missed that I had
that move a bishop a bishop might even
be good here I'll take it
no no no no no less than a minute give
me a check and now let's do this mmm
yeah let's go I need to keep throwing
punches with ya I know it's a very
limited material but I'm gonna try and
make it happen with just this silly
little pond right here throwing them
into c7 keep the initiative okay I get
to pick this guy up let's check at the
rook give a night check that's working
out so far take a look mm-hmm Oh fearful
I'm fearful I'm very fearful Oh
I throw another check-in you're not done
with your checks you're not done with
your checks just yet don't give your
opponent a moment to breathe he's
running away back here okay defend
somehow 32 seconds it's going to be a
mouse race right
just don't lose on time Queen takes
bishop I don't know just go here oh boy
don't get me down eh - man let's go here
Knight fork don't take with the pawn
I got a queen
don't make me okay now there it's a
check it's a check I'll probably need
him ah free move all right here they're
down on time Oh
96 yeah 96 4335 I got 28 all right this
is maybe the last one
Wow all right let's do it
I think it's important to actually use
this pawn as some defense so we're gonna
go with that
how about it I don't know that you're
any safer there King mmm okay do bishop
in alrighty
give your Bishop up I'll put my bishop
right here on f4 all right give me that
guy all right Bishop here as soon as
possible uh no right here you could do
that and
my pawns forward okay I'm already
preparing Queen sex bishop check attack
the King keep moving forward I got
another bishop mm-hmm all right let's
put him together how about right here
dark square control Bishop takes pawn I
think I might do that
okay slight lead on the clock here I
don't know each pawn attack you're gonna
give me a knight to work with let's see
what you got maybe I do this even okay
okay
fight my pawn forward Oh bishop here huh
that's what you have lined up actually
give me a rook how about that yes
give me the rook I could take this pawn
okay there might be some discoveries
like rook here and a knight drop there
mm-hmm
thought you might do that well okay my
Kings can
to find a nice pocket right here I got
some pieces to work with take their
night out a night drop into f2 it's
dangerous less than 40 seconds take that
clean and now we start throwing punches
like this right here and we hit the
Queen again like that Forks they got to
take here I'm not going to take I don't
want to give off the two pieces for the
Queen and back on the Queen mm-hmm okay
here oh boy there let's go here take the
bishop with check this was a good move
Oh or was it please no please don't have
anything good
Oh gonna hurt me
they have a queen yet you goof I still
have a queen oh this is big trouble
do they have any time don't make me take
that piece please say no what's this
again just run away no time they don't
mean turn back to turn oh man ah 32
we're not gonna get another game in 106
43 38 34 33 33 32 front-page I'll take
front-page man how did I do
2 losses when when all right there we go
Hawaiian tournament is officially over
45-minute one crazy craziness all right
to the whoa 100 of you were in this one
good games to the hundred of you all
right not bad as a created created
tournament the hoang tournament 106
let's see who took part in this one
that's as far down okay got it
so we are at 106 43 38 not too far off
from maybe getting into the top three
let's see who else took part so wait
how'd I do lost lost win win loss win
win win win win not bad a few four
losses tough start in this top guy
what's the story with this guy what's
the story newly-created count remember
since this interesting very strong
crazy-house player I guess okay let's go
through see the players page two three
four five six almost there that's gonna
do it
alright again to the hundred of you that
took part in this good games all
you